welcome back to another episode of
chappelle's world how we doing out there
everybody
i'm doing great i'm doing really good
guys all right i don't know if i've
talked about it on here yet i don't
think i have
but uh
just really happy with myself because
i've hit eight years
off of alcohol
eight years off alcohol
some people going oh don't clap don't
clap
we all want someone to clap for us
we all we all want the clap
i mean it is an accomplishment
especially if you know where you're at
when you're
doing the damn thing and i will say
eight years off alcohol i don't say
sober
okay
so oh cause uh you still hit pop i still
hit pi i still hit the pot also yeah
like
even if i didn't hit pot
i still wouldn't say
sober because i feel like that's
you know like this program that people
go through like there's a there's i
don't know i just think there's a
difference and
i don't know i want to respect those
people as best as i can and i think
like even wood smoking pot people were
like oh like you're sober and i go no
i'm not like people that are sober are
people that are
you know out there fighting on a
different level
than i am like i can handle pot
i keep saying potato
look i can handle it i can handle pot
you know
i can't handle pot easily in [ __ ] 70s
you're juiced to the gills on claret and
d right now yeah cause my peep analogies
bro no don't swear oh sorry two minutes
in dang it
sorry do you want to try it again no no
no
no it's okay i'll uh i'll beep it or
something
beep
because i've been on beep
allergy season
paulin's like what's up but no it's it's
actually cool actually
every time i think about the fact that i
don't drink i actually feel really
really really really good about it
you know even with all the years like it
like if me being away from it
i actually feel really good about it it
is it is tough it's not easy
it's not easy well especially in
my thing like when i you know when i was
drinking it sounded like i was just
going out beating up people
and hurting people and stuff and i
wasn't doing all that but
uh i mean i probably hurt people
emotionally not physically
not physically hey
that's not me i'm not that guy but i
think
you know just the way i was acting
there's this uh someone said it to me
before
about this like what
alcohol can do to someone emotionally to
where they're not necessarily
you know
doing wrong to others but
just the wrongs they're doing to
themselves and the thought process that
that they have about themselves as an
individual that's what i was like really
struggling with so
i'm just really happy that i'm here
today what meatball you you laughing
because
i don't
i don't drink are you am i a nerd to you
and those are the people i can't stand
like whenever i can't stand a meatball
either
oh you're saying no
i can't say the people that try to boo
you when you oh you quitter i go oh god
it's always that'll go you should quit
quit talking right now
yeah quit talking get out of my face
yeah i remember uh i remember when i
when i got sober
i remember when i got
when i stopped drinking
see what i did there when i first
stopped drinking
i think that's when i started
to go back um
almost to the roots
and started going back to like hardcore
in punk rock shows
and i remember that was like the first
time
you know i actually felt like free again
or felt like i was like uh on this
path to be free again because it was it
was a super quick uh transition i got
quit the next thing i know i'm at a punk
rock show in a pit martian i remember a
beer can was kicked on my face and that
was like a sign to be like hey god's
telling you don't go back to it and uh
i don't know just felt it's just there's
like this feeling i got where i just was
able to like
oh now i can rise now i have this
foundation to be able to like walk
it's crazy it's crazy how to do that to
you
you ball you should quit
actually you know what's funny meatball
don't even drink
you don't drink at all
i do just not a lot yeah you don't
really drink really drink
meatball drink i love this stuff yep
i remember one time yeah again like i
mean i got so many drunk stories but who
i mean who cares huh who cares
you know hey all right here's a trivia
question okay what was the first thing i
ever got drunk off of wild turkey damn
next got any other brain busters you
know right
that was so bad
that was so
fast that was the worst trivia game yeah
ever was the last thing i got drunk off
wild turkey damn it did i tell you that
already
no you just said you you that was your
drink so i figured that was a drink yeah
yeah but uh also a lot of people do
reach out to me
and i i want to say this here it's
because
it's hard to
reply to so many of these on on
instagram but a lot of people do reach
out to me asking for advice
on how to
get clean or just better their lives and
[Music]
the only thing i can really say
to everybody is accountability
if you hold account accountability for
yourself
then that's fine you know that's that
mean that that'll get you on that path
also
um don't make it about anyone else
just make it all about
yourself make it all about you
uh people are gonna you know
the people that you kind of burn br or
have burned bridges within
you know through your hectic journey
they're gonna say the things that they
want to say about you and
you gotta let that be
so you got to just
you know let people say what they say
and just focus on bettering yourself so
make it all about you
and hold and take accountability so
that's all i can really say about that
but good luck to everybody out there
on that type of journey
now
for exciting news
my band's going in the studio oh damn
yeah we're going in the studio first
week of may cool yeah we're going to do
uh some recordings we're going to put
out an e we're going to put out like an
ep oh that's time yeah then we're going
to put on like myspace because like you
know bands seem to be doing really well
oh yeah
yeah i did so that's where we're going
to put it and you know we're going to
just have like merch
no no it's actually kind of cool yeah
kind of crazy how many songs are you
going to try and we're going to do a
five song ep how cool and then
we're going to
then we're actually
currently writing an album right now so
then we'll have like a i don't know like
10 song album
i think yeah it's kind of crazy huh that
is why it's wild i don't know what to
think it's going to be wild being in the
studio
just be behind a microphone is it worth
the can you even
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it was at that time
chappelle's life
i am the the kanye of the punk rock
hardcore
that's what everybody's saying yeah yeah
that's what everyone's saying people
were talking about it you know what's
kind of cool about being in this band is
that
it has such a solid buzz that people are
really really interested in hearing the
band and
wanting to see the band and they love
the clips that i've posted of the band
so it's actually kind of cool that it is
getting a solid response and because i'm
working my ass off because i'm like hey
i don't want to suck i don't want this
to be bad at all and like i think about
it uh
there's some bands that have been around
for a really long time
right
and then they'll come out with like a
new record and i'm not saying this is
any genre any genre
and maybe they haven't made a record in
a while and then they all of a sudden
they want to make a record and then
they'll make a record that sounds like
it's from [ __ ]
2001 or something and i'm like hey
you hear you don't hear
you don't hear whatever not saying that
they have to follow what everyone's
doing but at least like
give it the modern sound
does that make any sense yeah it makes
sense
is that where you're going to try is
that what you're trying to like
well because like in your stuff all my
all my inspirations are from are like a
lot of older bands bands that have come
before some new some knew but a lot a
lot of the inspirations off of what i'm
creating is from bands that come before
so
uh but also with that being said you
kind of have to look at
what's going on to kind of get an idea
to like oh my god this is going to oh i
could do this with this and oh it's cool
to do this now because i think cause you
know what it is i think the older
generation there was just a time
especially in the the world of like punk
rock and hardcore people
would judge you if you try to do
anything different or try to
uh if you listen to any like if you were
punk rock that was it
that was it that's all you can listen to
you can't listen to anything else but
that but nowadays you have this this
younger generation where you can [ __ ]
did i did i cuss again
you know you did
[Laughter]
it was at that time
[Laughter]
no all right let's take a break from me
talking so i can talk some more
and guess what i'm going to talk about
i'm going to talk about one of the best
kratom in the kratom's in the game right
now and that is happy hippo okay kratom
uh i use kratom to fire my brain
before show punk rock shows podcasts
it's like a limitless pill uh it's a
great focus product one of the best that
i've used best part it's all natural
okay so you have to worry about anything
crazy you have to freak out like i do
when i take uh clarendon d for my
allergies uh why don't you go ahead and
visit happyhippos.com
and use promo code thick boy for 20 off
and that is for life and also you can
use that code as many times as you want
so once again happy hippo herbals.com
and use promo code thickboy for 20 off
for a life
no i look that's the thing i love i love
that this younger generation has been
able to
just go hey i don't care we're going to
play whatever we want to play and we're
going to play the way we want to play it
and and i think
for me i think i've always been that way
i think i've always been someone that's
like hey i like this too
yeah i like uh
slipknot but hey guess what i also like
some newfound glory songs you ever hear
the newfound glory you oh you have
yeah i don't know if you did you ever
get up you never got into pop punk
though not really not really
um
we talked about it
oh yeah you green day and stuff like
that green yeah
well
yeah i guess grenade but green day's
kind of i don't know
i don't know where to put green day and
that and i mean it's pop punk but it's
like pantheon
i don't know
like
emo pop punk yeah who do they have yes
see they have those type in emo
and see what they put
it's still like [ __ ] uh mother
fall out boy oh fallout
i saw them in concert uh one time i saw
them back in 2006 it was when that album
would go down
going down when that
i loved that video that music video
first
it had like a deer yeah it was dope it
was cool
uh i saw them in concert and i never
really listened to fallout boy before
but when i saw them in concert when that
album came out i want to say was o5 was
it o5
yeah yeah it was o5 it was it was
it was them panic at the disco and panic
at the disco wasn't even huge yet i was
yeah this is
121 million views on this oh wow
there is a deer it's just a man that's a
deer no their deer comes up
let's skip through
dude look at look at the time with this
yeah maybe it wasn't as good as i
thought no no i mean
yo yo yo yo go back go back
hit pause
right there
hey
you see that man's teeth
they're bad they're not good they're not
good but he's like half dear but that's
but that's what hey they probably were
like hey you got bad teeth
let's make them look cool yeah and i
respect that
i respect that all the way look at the
way they dress back in the day
that was the thing dude
so much nostalgia this song was on my uh
workout playlist for you work you could
work out to this song oh yeah oh really
well i guess it does amp up
i meant i didn't meet pete once i saw
him he said hi to me um that doesn't
count people randomly just say hi to me
even though like they don't know me you
had a welcoming face yeah i do i guess i
do have a very very approachable my like
i saw mike epps in the airport
and he uh i love my capsules i love mike
f suit i love mike
yeah he said he said hi to me he walked
right up to me shook my hand i was like
oh man
he plays uh richard pryor in the new uh
hbo show winning time about the latest
yeah what is that show it's awesome
it's about so it's just about the lakers
the era with magic johnson yeah it's
about to come up uh of the lakers it's
awesome john c reilly yeah i saw that
john but it's a good show it's great
yeah i gotta check that out yeah check
it out huh check it out check it out
check it out uh but yeah
uh what's it talking about shout out to
fallout boys
punk shout out to pop punk those videos
were pretty much all the same they were
just so emotional
and they're always about a girl
a girl that broke their heart
weezer's papa no i don't know if
weezer's pop punk
i don't think weezer's pop punk
weezer's kind of like
out
is it garage rock
let's see what they say about wizards
type in weezer they usually put this
right here emo popping in in the 90s
with bands like jimmy world to get up
kids weezer and promise her shout out to
jimmy world shout out to mesa arizona
type in weezer
i didn't think they considered that rock
band that's what they that's what it
says no so it says uh genres right there
it always says
powerpop powerpop that's what i get i
consider them more power pop than uh
like emo
actually maybe that first record
pinkerton do you listen to much weezer
casey
uh dabble dabble
you should check out the album
and report back
the album pinkerton okay check out that
album i want to say that was after their
blue album which is the
the one that has my name is jonas
now i'm carrying nowhere
i i think this after the blue album
oh what's that song
what do you mean
i used to be i used to play it on the
guitar
if you want to is that what album is it
i don't know go to
type in blue album
by we weezer
by weeza we listen to weeza
yes so that came out 94. so it's
obviously not my name is jonas say it
ain't something
oh yeah mm-hmm
[Music]
yeah that's a good album you should you
should check that album out yeah i guess
if you never really got into the pop
punk world i mean i could throw some
bands at you that i think you might like
uh or just to check out so check out
that album that's well that's power pop
um
let's see
well um
check out saves the day stay what you
are okay that's a good
album i think you i think you can check
that out i think that would be so my
next homework is the uh
emo pop punk
what'd you say emo pop punk specifically
or just pop punk in general
yeah uh yeah let's do let's do
pop punk in general okay so probably
because the metal uh oh yeah experiment
that we've been doing i think it's been
tremendously successful really okay yeah
tell me about it let's talk about it
casey's
um so the assignment was to listen to
metallica right yeah you listen to ride
the lightning or no what did i forget
which one it's been a couple weeks now
since we maybe or whatever yeah so you
listened
you know good news bad news good news
bad news i'll probably probably kill
them all i'm not into metallica not in
metallica just just okay just not my
thing
but
that's okay i don't judge people when
they're not into something i look i did
the homework i'm not going to come in
and fake it and be like i'm a i have a
metallica head now yeah and i don't
think i don't want people to like i
don't want to make people feel bad
because they don't like yeah i hate when
people hang that [ __ ] over someone's so
that's the bad news good news
i discovered
a little band called pentagram
wow
whoa
hey
that's a deep
dive yeah i
love pentagram which so i might just be
a doom metal guy
wow
who knew
who knew
that's dude that's a deep dive they
actually have a documentary
about pentagram
uh that you should check out
type it in
crazy story about the lead singer there
last days here last days here yes last
days here that documentary
i think you i think you would like it
you should check that out
crazy story about this dude but great
yes great band
seemed like a street black set post page
oh i mean look at them
very
bone chilling music
his voice is sick right isn't it
wait so how did you okay how did you
come about pentagram then uh i don't
even know i was just you know scrolling
i was just trying to listen to metal yep
found pentagram i think that my friend
john bellino might have had a skate part
to it so i recognized it so i had that
like positive association and then i'm
like uh i could i could definitely get
into this like i could just sit and like
listen to this album yeah so i wonder if
you're in the doom
area
very interesting yeah very revealed
what's what's funny is a lot of a lot of
skaters escape to a lot of doom metal
yeah it's like fun to skate too and it
just goes good with the sound of like
the skateboard landing and the pop and
all that stuff i feel like that like
when i think of skate videos a lot of
times i feel like
the the
sound of the music that like goes with
it pretty solid obviously a lot of them
do but
specifically doom metal just does
something to it yeah so i think the
metal experience i mean the metal uh
experiment
has been a tremendous success yeah i'm
i'm going to watch this documentary as
well watch that document pentagram i'll
rewatch it too i haven't seen it since
it came out but it's a really good dock
maybe we should watch it together we
could do a companion like companion yeah
we can cook
that's what we're gonna do
so the man
do a little companion yeah the metal uh
that was a tremendous success and now
we'll go
pop punk yeah i wonder i wonder where
else you go from there if you like
pentagram yeah i wonder where else
the sky is the limit it's opened many
doors yeah i wonder
man that's a that's a good one wow that
caught me off guard
that caught me off guard big time
i i
oh wow
casey that's a good one i'm gonna be
coming in with like a pentagram shirt no
yeah i mean yeah but but that makes
sense
right okay yeah yeah because you are
more of a
oddly enough doom kind of has this like
mel mellow
side to it
like whereas metallica is pretty yeah
yeah
a lot of
where
the doom is kind of just
there and it lets you let you just get
chill like this where's metallic you
gotta like
[Music]
doom damn good on you good fine
uh there's this uh
series that was on vh1
gosh
i hate that i cannot remember it but it
was the oh it's the evolution of
i think the evolution of metal
metal evolution
metal evolution yeah you can watch it on
apple tv or amazon prime oh
it's out what dude watch that okay
that's a good uh
good series of watch this dude
goes through
all the different like
genres like subgenres of uh metal like
all these bands that i don't know that
to where you just see so much metal
influence like coming from everywhere i
think he talks about i think he's
talking about the sticks
in this
we like the sticks
what's that song they got the jig is up
i don't know
[Music]
yeah
[Laughter]
dude that's a whole era of music i don't
necessarily think i
really got that deep into i don't know
if i got that deep into
the sticks
um journey
uh
what else is like kind of like that era
um
yes
would boston be be that
aryo speedwagon i like songs
i like songs but i don't i don't know if
i necessarily
ever really bumped an album to where
or just like i don't know
i just i don't think i've ever really
given those kind of albums a chance i
don't like don't stop believing i hate
yeah i mean you almost listen to like
journey or something like ironically
yeah you know you're not literally like
sitting down putting down and be like
i'm just gonna
i know there's some journey fans out
there that probably understand that that
band like
you know to the core i've just never met
those people
i feel like most people majority people
i guess of my and i guess i got to go
off my generation
most people in my generation i don't
know i don't yeah necessarily it's just
the previous generation not to dismiss
it i'm like oh nothing the previous
generation oh yeah yeah but i mean
there's tons of i know some people who
love it but i feel like
yeah it's just kind of there it's
there's there's another side of
rock that is like that as well that i
never really got into but i like songs
and uh these bands are kind of made fun
of
but it's like uh you hear a band called
crossfade
they had this song yes you have you know
this song they have a bank they have a
song their biggest hit was this song
called cold
i never meant to be so cold
what i really meant to say
is i'm sorry for the way yeah i know
that yeah i don't know what you really
call those kind of bands yeah guys that
look like that chin strap bands yeah is
that what they got yeah oh they all have
that's like a soul patch so
yeah they all have the soul patch with
bands like that
like a breaking benjamin
i like becky benjamin you like breaking
measurement
do you really uh-huh
they have a song i mean one song it's
the same kind of thing one i wonder what
song it is you probably know it it's um
um
a
it's what's it gonna mean angels
is it called angels i don't know let's
listen
angels fall
i like that song i'll have to cut this
out but let's listen and confirm
no it's not i like this song
do you remember this oh it's so cold
is it so cold i don't know but i
appreciate what they do they're really
talented musicians all the way and they
kill it they kill it live they're
probably great live bands
uh do you remember this one song casey
uh i think it was the only song this
band had
but the band was called smiled empty
soul and they had that song i do it for
the drugs
i do it just a villa
you never
listen
when i sing songs
i'm always way off on how i'm singing
the song because we were like i've never
heard that song and then when they hear
it i go oh you were singing it really
fast
uh
what is it called
bottom of a bottle
you ever hear that song i know you have
no
uh uh
maybe like anything any music with like
that kind of voice
[Laughter]
i think is
just goofy really
yeah
you got to hear the chorus anybody's
like [ __ ] told me yeah yeah that's
right down to the shore yeah i can't do
it it's tough
it's tough that's why i say i like songs
but i can't get down with a full album
i just i just know and i know that
because i go when i hear this song i'll
i won't go any further
than this song and i've tried to look up
and i have some of those bands i have
looked up other songs
but i'm like
all right
[Music]
what about tool
yeah
tools tools great tools great tool was
like one of the first or one of the last
concerts i saw before the pandemic oh
really
at the staples center yeah that was uh
october
actually i think it might have been
morrissey was the last concert i went to
before the pandemic
but yeah
man that was eight i'm i'm really
excited about your
update
thanks matt that yeah
i like that you went you went outside
yeah you know anything worth doing is
worth doing right so what you i forgot i
can't remember if you just said this or
not but you
um so what you were listening to
metallica and then what they
they just happen to pop up i think so i
i use youtube music
i don't have spotify okay and i think i
was just like metal
and just like
so it'll just have like a list of like a
hundred so i mean infinite so i was just
like kind of skimming through and then
recognized i must have recognized
pentagram from like a skate section i
was like yes sick
i wonder what other doom metal bands you
would like yeah
type of doom metal
sad with you yeah
candle mass
paradise lost electric wizard you know
these are there's people that do doom
and sludge
let me ask you this what's sludge sludge
uh a band that i would say is sludge
oh mastodon i recognize that yeah
it's more uh
[Music]
modern
sludge is kind of
almost a muddy
kind of
sound like i don't know how to explain
it sludge too much i never really
listened to much of it i want but i
wonder because
some sludge also
because it combines
doom metal and hardcore punk
yeah that's what uh
typically harsh and abrasive uh-huh
what's the band i'm blanking on
i can't believe i'm blanking on this
band
and it's making me mad
because their drummer's my favorite
drummer and i'm really blanking on this
man
and it's gonna be and someone's gonna
punch me in the face another one uh
someone you want me ball oh
but
the drummer is my favorite drummer type
of dale crover
buzz osbourne what the hell is
melvin's the melvins gosh i cannot think
of it i could have told you the melvins
oh you know the melvins oh
really that's another good band check
them out okay
you check out the melvins i've seen them
live they're really good live too
yeah but that drummer dale crover is an
amazing drummer that's dave one of dave
groves dave gross
dude i do so much podcasting i am
this is what
the fifth one i've done this week
and folks if i sounded crazy today
i'm sorry
but i've done a lot of talking
it makes my brain go
you know when a camera lights action
when it's on plus declared in d plus the
clarendon d which i feel amazing right
now i sound better huh yeah you do yep
see what claire d can do for you shut up
meatball kick in the face
so forgive me if i'm a
i'm a little out of it right now also
you were like uh case can
like let's say 12 hours later like could
i take this again yeah
[Laughter]
pills freaked me out i could tell phil's
freaking me out like yeah brad it's
clever i was like
yeah i said okay i said this lasts for
12 hours
so
in another 12 hours can i take another
one if i'm feeling if i'm still feeling
bad
yeah dude go nuts it's great indeed
you're [ __ ] well because i don't know
if you know this you for for people that
know about clairton d
regular claritin fine you can get it
over the counter i mean it's all over
the counter but
claire indeed you got to go back there
to the pharmacy with a card that says
hey i want to get claritin d and they
want they go you want the off brand on a
real brand then they ask you for your id
they ask your address all this stuff
because you want to know why people kids
are making meth
i said kids
you're making meth with clarendon d
which how do people discover this stuff
how does this come about
what
clarendon d the thing that helps me that
helps me survive pollen
claritin d
i don't know what you kids are doing out
there but you need to stop knock it off
knock it off has allergies well i have
allergies and i need this for my
allergies and what you're doing is
taking up all this time to cause because
you think you're freaking
what was that bad breaking or
bad breaking
dyslexic breaking bad
what if we just stopped the meth
entirely just by going hey
knock it off knock it off this what if
this podcast is the one that does it see
how crazy i am right now i said bad
breaking yeah you're all messed up well
i've never seen the show
what no
why not
listen i didn't go
huh you didn't like metallica
wow
yeah but yeah but i tried metallica you
tried without you you didn't try
breaking bad oh you don't know i just i
didn't like it
i just yeah
yeah it's okay if you try and don't like
it yeah that's fine
why not try it dude you know who i saw
when i was hiking yesterday pat medler
baby no i did not see ben miller
one of my one of my all-time favorites
from one of my all-time favorite shows
the only show i've ever watched from
start to finish
little house in the prairie how did you
know i was a little house on the prairie
friend i don't know but it wasn't that
no i did not see a home girl uh
charlie hunnum
anarchy dude charlie hunnam he's yeah he
was also uh
arthur have you seen king arthur no i
haven't guy richie directed it this is
recent yeah it's on netflix it's good
it's awesome initially it did uh
betterly at the box office i think it
was going up against like i don't know
batman or something stupid yeah i wonder
if that that is a thing for for movies
and [ __ ] like you you know when the
release is like dropped because i i've
talked to a you know pretty high
producer before okay uh and he was
saying yeah a lot of times if you drop
it on when you're going up against a lot
of stuff even though the movie could be
really good yeah it may not have that
immediate success because of what it's
going up against
charlie hunnam though he's yeah
he's a handsome i know i was like bro
you need to chill out bro you better
stop playing get off my mountain quit
playing it's my plan it's my mountain
dawg being all handsome yeah
shredded i was like
well you're harley at
dawn i've actually met him before too i
met him once but i did waved when i said
and he was like wait you waved you you
waved to him like
where did how did you meet him before
this is fascinating you and charlie
hunnam yeah friends
no we're not friends no i'm in a long
time if you can wave to somebody while
you're on a hike and they wave back like
hey i met him off uh wilshere
and said i said hi to him and i was like
yo man what's up big fan
and he was he was
extremely nice so you think he
recognized you from that meeting for the
for the wave i remember faces most
people don't i can remember faces it's
like whenever i go back to a city and
see fans or whatever i remember their
faces oh really i go i met you last time
i was like you
yeah i'm like rain man of faces wow and
birthdays
birthdays and faces
that's the name of the episode was your
birthday your uh september 21st
is that right right
you want to know why i know that yes
oh
i also share a birthday with someone
and who works in the studio
who may be
the reason we're all in the studio oh
you're oh yeah
you're march 18th yep
yeah
see i got this wow don't ever question
my rayman hey man mentality
yeah he did not spoon feed it to me hot
water i still had to guess
i don't like y'all anyway
this you know this whole operation
over no don't say that that's declared
indeed talking it's declaring the
default sit down you're not going
anywhere you stayed to the job stone
clarity talking i talk too much i talk a
lot
yeah why don't we uh um
you want to jump into a playlist
oh before we get into a playlist uh
there's this thing i want to do with
people uh with fans where
uh i would love for you guys to you know
hit us in the comments
with a list of artists that i should
probably take a deep dive on
um that i
never really
looked at before
but you guys would think i'd be
interested in based off of what you
know about me you know and so i'll take
it where are your blind spots musically
like blind spots give them like a
direction okay that's a fair question
that's a good question good good answer
good answer good answer
survey says
get it okay good that's a good
uh my wait what was it blind spot yeah
that means what i don't like no not
necessarily what you don't like
i don't like um stuff that you haven't
even given a chance like uh
the breaking bad of music oh the breakup
what have i not given a chance
um
or maybe just something reggae
okay i've never given reggae a chance
um edm
you never give an edm a chance
but i feel like edm's kind of a
culture
do people actually like
like if you're not at a festival like
think about it like if you're not at a
festival do you listen to like
do you listen do these
edm artists have full albums
um
marshmallow does oh mar well marshmallow
does sure
we know that
i have no idea what he's talking about
yeah
um
let's actually look that up
i actually don't know that
oh yeah i mean rolling stone ranked the
30 greatest edm albums so yeah oh well
so this is a perfect example so like
okay so what do they consider edm
ah
so is edm been a genre for a minute
because now there's something like moby
and lcd sound system in here
that's weird i don't know if i would
have ever considered
whoa
edmund stands for what electric
electronic electronic dance music is
what it stands for it's music
well i love daft punk
yeah i guess when i was thinking edm i
was thinking um
but that's a good example so maybe
there's like some sort of modern edm
that you haven't been exposed to that i
haven't been exposed to yeah well
there's a lot i haven't been exposed to
um
i'm actually saving this because there's
a lot more
that i have to do
but i'm deep diving mac miller right now
and i'm like man i gotta
i gotta like really do a d calm down
meatball okay chill out yeah we'll have
to get meatball uh over here and give
him a microphone for that yeah because
uh yeah mac miller tattoo i do uh i
that's an artist i you know never really
gave a chance i don't
not that i
like i've heard his songs and i would go
[ __ ] that's dope i don't think i've
ever
you know his a song of his ever came on
i was like what the hell is this i've
never done that i just never
partaken in it and so i'm doing a deep
dive on him and i'll save that for
another episode we'll title it the mac
miller deep dive or whatever but that's
one that i'm like
whoo there is a lot to uncover he's a
different
different different breed
um
yeah meatball sent me a mac miller
playlist to uh that i've been bumping it
but i've been reading up on them and
like watching interviews you should
watch mac miller in the moscow family
it's a tv show that tv show i remember
that tv show i remember that it was on
mtv
uh yeah let's do a playlist for this
week so what are we talking about this
week
the playlist
we're gonna do crossfade cold
we're gonna we're gonna go yeah we're
gonna do a playlist for these bands yeah
yeah yeah let's do
benjamin yeah
um what was this song
so cold wait so cool
two songs in a row yeah so cold
uh i'll do trust company the band's
called trust company
i forget what the song is called
um can we go follow that boy sugar we're
going down yeah let's go volleyball
we're going down you know how they got
their name and where they got their name
fallout boy from no it was the comic in
the simpsons so in the in the simpsons
there was like a comic book character
and it was fall out boy really yeah and
so that's where that's a deep cut
because i would have never known that i
don't know how and i've watched a lot of
simpsons here let's look it up sim sons
wow
that's pretty cool
um
there's this song called
gosh i forget what the band is called
but i know the name of the song
it's called stupid girl
all right we'll just put it in but
stupid girl
i'm saying there's like a spider or
something like that
um
we're doing all the i don't know what
you call this genre you either
yeah
uh smile empty soul bottom of a bottle
what's that uh man can you take it all
away
you shove it in my face
[Laughter]
we're giving a lot of love to these fans
y'all better bump this
playlist so hard
in your car
by yourself take it all
away um
will do weezer
what was this
say it ain't so
um
how many is that eight two four six
eight yeah eight okay
and it hard with like a fun can
hey throw it throw it in there throw in
a
pentagram
let's see where's my pentagram throwing
pentagram oh this is actually this is
this would expose me pretty pretty bad
this is my youtube music
i don't know i don't know
but
shout out to youtube music
yeah olivia rodriguez at the top of your
list i love her i think she i think she
likes me too yeah
i'll tell you you said hi
let's see what pentagram song you want
to rock with
i want to do one more weezer song
and we'll top it off with that
it's called pink triangle
it's off that pinkerton album
all right
all right thank you guys for tuning in
to this episode uh but before i go uh
tour dates please come see me on the
road shout out to salt lake city
a lot of you guys showed up for me
uh that means a lot i had a blast with
y'all so uh san diego hopefully you guys
can do the same that'd be great uh i'll
be at mike drop comedy club may 6th and
7th and then uh may 12th i'll be doing a
one-nighter in the hometown at stand-up
live in phoenix and then june 24th and
25th i'll be at comedy connection in
east uh providence rhode island uh oh oh
i failed to mention
um
i guess when this comes out i'll already
be out there but i'll be in austin texas
at moon tower comedy festival uh it'll
be going on all weekend this drops onto
thursday so it'll be going on all
weekend and if you're out in austin
texas come say hi to me or come to any
other shows that i'm on just go to the
moon tower
website and you're able to like click on
my name and then you see all the shows
uh that i'm on i think casey's gonna try
to pull that up
tower dot uh blue tower comedy festival
type in that
and
i think if yep
yeah my name is on there that is cool
this is great great
great gate you know what i'm saying
listen i've done a lot of talking
i've done so much talking
a lot of talking
four days a week talking
anyways but you can go to that uh
website and find
my name and uh
all right thank you guys for tuning in
boom